65 اسيرا اوكرانيا وثلاثه مرافقين اضافه
الى سته افراد من الطاقم كلهم قضوا في
حادثه تحطم الطائره الروسيه العسكريه في
منطقه بجرود الحدوديه على الجانب الروسي
زيلينسكي الذي اتهم موسكو بالتلاعب بحياه
السجناء الاوكرانيين طلب بفتح تحقيق
دولي من الواضح ان روس يتلاعبون بحياه
السجناء الاوكرانيين ومشاعر اهاليهم
وعواطف مجتمعنا يجب اثبات كل الحقائق قدر
الامكان على الاعتبار ان اسقاط الطائره تم
على الاراضي الروسيه الواقعه خارج
سيطرتنا موسكو التي قالت انها كانت تنقل
الاسرى بهدف تبادلهم اتهمت من جانبها كيف
بتنفيذ عمليه ارهابيه كان القاده
الاوكرانيين على علم تام بالتبادل المرتقب
وتم اطلاعهم على كيفيه تسليم السجناء لكنه
تم اسقاط طائره ال 76 بثلاثه
صواريخ لكن الاستخبارات الاوكرانيه نفت
امتلاكها اي معلومات موثوقه او شامله عن
هويات او اعداد الاشخاص الذين كانوا على
متن الطائره وقالت في بيان انه كان من
المفترض ان تجري عمليه تبادل لسجناء
الاربعاء لكن موسكو لم تبلغها باي خطط
لنقل الجنود الاسرى الى منطقه بجرود حيث
اسقطت الطائره ووسط تبادل الاتهامات
وتحميل كل طرف الاخر المسؤوليه يعقد مجلس
الامن الدولي جلسه طارئه بهذا الصدد بطلب
من الجانب
الروسي